look it's like this I'm sick I don't
feel well
and I was like I need to do this review
I don't feel like showering up I'll just
wear the beanie because without the Pina
it look like this [ __ ] is unacceptable
point is it'll feel weird at first but
we'll get through it
I know I may be down the road I'll be
like oh man I should've just showered
and gotten all ready for that review
right now I'm gonna do like this pretty
on brand I feel like I should be in the
pet cemetery let's review it
[Music]
Pet Sematary herding cats is not just a
phrase by the way realize with this
thumbnail when we get all the cat people
now they're much more needy than dog
people they're needy and they act like
they're not needy
he's a pretty cat though God you look
like a model like you're like pet
sematary you don't look scraggly at all
you should this is Ramsay and he's a
really sweet cat who wants the [ __ ] out
of it okay so Pet Cemetery is the new
movie by Stephen King it's I can't
sorry Ramsay so pet cemetery is the
newest movie based on a Stephen King
novel which we're hitting a pretty good
stride now we're two for two for looking
at the new wave of Stephen King movies
with it we have Pet Sematary now whose
cat hair floating everywhere if there's
cat hair on me in this review whatever
Pet Sematary stars Jason Clark he's the
father and husband of his family they
moved to this house in the middle of
nowhere in a small town you know pretty
Stephen King ish and in the woods behind
this house there's a cemetery where
people apparently bury their pets which
I just learned cemetery is totally
misspelled in this movie in this book in
this story just realize that hey that's
a lot of years to not notice that point
is it may or may not involve a cat think
it's brought back to life and now we
have zombie creepy cat and there's more
to it as the story unfolds because
Stephen King's that's what I like about
this movie like about its what I like
about Stephen King stories when you
watch them they're distinctly Stephen
King stories there aren't other horror
stories that really feel like that other
horror stories may have actually taken
beats from Stephen King and most other
people if they were to make a story like
this I feel like it feels a little
convoluted there are a lot of storylines
that weave together I don't know but we
used together smoothly Stephen King
generally speaking makes it work it's
the people who had dapped it to movies
that's where it [ __ ] up alright in some
of his books maybe doesn't work either
but the guy hasn't made a name for
himself for that not working that's why
I notice in here and here it just feels
distinctly like Stephen King it's not
really about one cat it's not really
about other things that may or may not
happen it's really the story of this
family and the people in it and horror
things are built around them and that's
what makes this good I will say I kind
of crave a few more answers as to how
deep it goes and maybe that was
explained in the book maybe it wasn't I
would say it's there to keep the
intrigue alive but I a couple more
questions if they were answered would
still keep the intrigue alive just want
to know a couple more things and
everyone in here was actually a really
good job Jason Clark is great I mean
Jason Clark is he is great Jason Clark's
one of those actors like you know his
name you might know him as that guy but
you know he's good John lifts out needs
no introduction there is a point in this
movie where the little girl that if
there's a lot asked of her she doesn't
write for herself she's not the little
kid from looper who I feel like it's
like the metric because that kid in
looper was really good the movie does
feel a bit short and part of my short I
mean I I feel like things were cut out I
mean there could be a lot more lore
explained in here like I mentioned
earlier there could be a lot more that
happens the creep factor could build up
before alright here's more of what's
happening you can have more creepiness
you can have more cat is all I have to
say cat creepy right but as it stands
it's like alright creep factor a little
more happening and Stephen King pretty
to the point I suppose that's why it's
hard to adapt Stephen King stories to
the big screen unless you split it up
into two halves like it I mean come on
there we Drudge through a whole there
was a lifetime in which Stephen King
adaptations were happening they were
coming to the big screen or the small
screen they were not that good stop with
that Shawshank Redemption [ __ ] all right
I know that that's great that's an
exception not the rule this movie has
solid acting a solid lead
it has good creep factor though I could
have had the creepiness build a bit
longer
it has good intrigue though I could have
delved into the Laura bit more so that
if he wants walking out of the movie but
in the end I walked out going that was
more enjoyable than a lot of horror
movies that happened these days as I
said before horror movies should be
telling the story of the characters end
them in horror things are built around
it and horror elements start invading
the family dynamic the home they start
invading the people's personal lives
this movie does that the story does that
it's not just scare scare scare because
there were a couple of jump scares it
was just at the beginning and then you
kind of calm down after that and there
wasn't it Easter Egg did you see it on
the road side of the road the sign it's
there in the end I will say pest
Cemetery is a good time no alcohol
required and was copped through that I
saw Pet Sematary have you seen it what
did you think about it was your favorite
Stephen King movie from the book
adaptation I think I asked that in every
Stephen King movie that's based off of a
book but I'm gonna ask it again because
like I said I'm sick and I feel like
[ __ ]
I'm gonna end this now whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]